Old Nan: I could tell you about Ser Duncan
the Tall, those were always your favorites.
George R.R. Martin: I have to do this, I have
to do a prequel.
So I started thinking about my history and
what would be a good area to write it and
I came up with the Dunk and Egg stuff.
I was particularly attracted that whole story
is built around a tournament and I love medieval
tournaments, reading about them, writing about
them.
There are, of course, some of them in the
main books but this was an opportunity in
a time of peace, not war, to look at a medieval
tilt tournament with all its pageantryand
the jousting and the combat.
And reveal little of Westerosi history.
Joffrey Baratheon: So this is the famous Book
of Brothers.
All the great deeds of all the great Kingsguard,
huh?
Ser Duncan the Tall.
Hah, four pages for Ser Duncan.
Must have been quite a man.
Jaime Lannister: So they say.
All boys dream of becoming knights.
The boys with talent dream of becoming Kingsguard.
The boys without talent, well, I wouldn't
know.
For centuries, the Kingsguard have been the
glory of the realm.
Aegon the Conqueror had established the order
as his personal guardians after uniting Westeros
with fire and blood.
He knew that some of his subjects wouldn't
take to conquest, and his dragons were no
use against knives in the dark.
No doubt surrounding himself with the greatest
knights in Westeros made his rule more palatable
and less foreign as well.
Everyone in his kingdoms soon knew the names
and some of the songs of the Kingsguard.
I certainly did from earliest days.
We protected the king and his family.
We killed his enemies and led his armies.
We gave him counsel when asked and kept his
secrets when not.
We swore to hold no lands, take no wives,
and father no children.
Like the Night's Watch, except with a real
job to do.
Was I awed to see my name inscribed in the
same book as my heroes?
Of course not.
I was sixteen and brilliant.
I knew I belonged there.
Beside the name of Ser Duncan the Tall, who,
as a hedge knight, broke several of Prince
Aerion Targaryen's teeth while defending a
Dornish woman.
He later rose to Lord Commander and burned
beside his King at Summerhall, because Ser
Duncan had sworn our oath.
Bronn: Justice is a funny thing.
For the poor, it's what keeps them alive - and
starving; Depending on how the local lord
feels about his woods, his streams, his crops.
For the rich, justice is what you get if you
are not careful enough - or rich enough.
Usually how it works is: you commit a crime
and the local lord sends his guards after
you; or your victim's family kills you and
the guards go after them instead.
Or you do nothing, and the guards come after
you anyway.
Either way, someone is brought before the
lord and he decides what's to be done.
Could be a fine, if you are rich enough to
pay.
Otherwise it's the dungeons, the chopping
block or the Wall.
If your family honor goes back hundreds of
years to a time when your ancestors hit other
men harder than they were hit, you had another
option: trial by combat.
You either fight your accuser, or you both
pick champions to fight on your behalf, and
the gods will favor the righteous man... as
long as he's also the strongest, the quickest
or the luckiest.
Once in a long while, you may get two real
highborn shits having a go at each other;
and one of them might be fool enough to demand
a trial by seven.
Exactly how it sounds: seven men against seven
men.
Makes for a good show,I guess.
But any man who's been in battle knows that
the more men involved, the less skill needed,
the more chance of accidents.
Just ask that Targaryen prince who got his
head staved in by his brother all those years
ago.
And all for some hedge knight.
Varys: A wheel with two hubs will not turn,
and a kingdom with two kings will burn, as
the saying goes.
Not that such a cost stopped anyone with even
the remotest claim and opportunity, much less
House Blackfyre.
Their rebellions consumed tens of years and
thousands of lives.
First Daemon's own, then his son, Daemon the
Second, who reigned for a night.
Then another son, Haegon, crowned by Bittersteel,
another legitimized bastard who had founded
the Golden Company to support the Blackfyre
claim.
When Haegon was executed, Bittersteel crowned
Haegon's elder son Daemon the Third, who,
in turn, was slain by the Lord Commander of
the Kingsguard, Ser Duncan the Tall.
Ray: "The War of the NinepennyKings", they
called it.
But I never saw a king or earned a penny.
After the war ended, I heard it all started
when an exiled royal bastard raised an army
of sellswords and the rightful king sent his
own army to stop an invasion.
Sounds simple, the way the Maesters tell it.
But an army isn't like a dog that comes when
you whistle.
The king calls on great lords, who call on
lesser lords, who send down their captains
to round up all the peasant men on the land
the lord claims to own.
If the lord is wise and generous, his new
soldiers are given steel swords and wooden
shields to fight his battles.
Most of our army fought with sharp sticks.
Singers still sing of the valiant heroes made
in the war.
Ser Brynden Tully, the "Blackfish."
Ser Tywin Lannister and Prince Aerys Targaryen.Ser
Barristan Selmy, the "Bold," who slew the
bastard pretender and ended the war at a stroke.
But the king whose crown we were defending
never came.
He mattered too much, I suppose.
His Hand commanded the crown's armies and
died valiantly in his son's arms.
Or so the singers say.
I never saw that, either.
I did see the soldiers when they came to our
village.
They declared I was too young to fight but
my brothers and friends were all going and
I wouldn't be left behind.
My oldest brother said I could be his squire,
though he wasn't a knight, just a pot boy
armed with a stolen kitchen knife.
He'd never need it.
I saw him collapse on our march from fever,
along with many from our village.
I saw our shoes fall apart on the road, our
clothes rot off our bodies and half of us
shitting our beds from the sickness and fear.
And then we got to the war.
In the Stepstones, I saw a mace cave in my
last brother's head, I saw the lord who led
us there cut down, and some other lord shout
that we were his now.
One day I looked around and realized all my
friends and kin were gone.
I was fighting beside strangers under a banner
I'd never seen.
Didn't know where I was or how to get home.
When a lord ran up shouting at us to form
ranks with our scythes and hoes, I couldn't
remember which side I was on.
Then the knights came down on us, faceless
men all in steel.
The thunder of their charge filled the world.
I closed my eyes.
Years later, after the war had faded into
songs, I opened them again and saw what I
had done and what I had become in the war
and since.
I went looking for a way back home.
I know I'll never reach it, but that doesn't
mean I don't need a guide.
Samwell Tarly: According to legend, House
Targaryen survived the Doom of Valyria thanks
to Daenys the Dreamer, who foresaw the calamity
and convinced her father to flee their homeland.
It could be true.
The Targaryens were always a bit more.
But as Maester Yandel points out, in the East,
the Targaryens were one of a thousand minor
noble families, and in Westeros, they became
kings.
Politics, not prophecy, could have drawn them
to our shores.
Politics can also explain the prophecies of
Daemon II Blackfyre, a Targaryen bastard rumored
to possess the family gift.
While posing as a hedge knight, he told a
future Lord Commander of the Kingsguard that
he dreamt of a dragon hatching at Whitewalls
Castle and took it as a sign that he'd win
the Iron Throne.
Perhaps if he'd slept a bit longer, he'd have
dreamt of the King's Hand putting down his
rebellion a day later, before it even began.
Most Maesters dismiss all Targaryen claims
of prophecy as mystic nonsense, a relic of
their Eastern ancestry.
To be fair, across the Narrow Sea, there isn't
a market without a Warlock from Qarth telling
fortunes or a shadowbinder from Asshai reading
fates in blood.
Or so I hear from the Maesters.
Pycelle: the Targaryens never stopped trying
to revive their dragons.
AerionBrightflame drank a draught of wildfire
and burned to death.
Aegon the Fifth tried to hatch stone dragon
eggs with sorcery and burned to death.
Jon Snow: Sam said you wanted to see me.
Aemon Targaryen: I did, indeed.
Jon Snow: Who are you?
Aemon Targaryen: My father was Maekar, the
First of his Name.
My brother Aegon reigned after him, when I
had refused the throne.
Robb Stark: What are you telling him now?
Old Nan: Only what the little Lord wants to
hear.
Robb Stark: Get your supper, I want some time
with him.
Aemon Targaryen: Mother’s looking for you…
Egg.